[Musique]
Daniel est la vigie de la pollution à
Fos-sur-Mer à Lhassa blement ils
traquent les fumée noire jaune ou rouge
des usines comme autant de preuves de la
pollution industrielle que respire les
habitants de la ville
chaque fois que j'ai un moment à chaque
fois que je vois dans la fumée dans la
maison là je monte à l'autre là c'est le
point le plus haut du village avec son
crochet bébé sur son église
et je vais me rendre compte un petit peu
de la pollution Kia
si les usines sont prêtes ou pas si
c'est tout va bien
là je suis en train de surveiller s'il y
a pas des panache qui se font surtout
ArcelorMittal et peut-être pourquoi pas
derrière il y a Lionel il y a
à tout à l'heure les industries
les enfants
c'est en travaillant sur le port de Fos
que Daniel a commencé observer les pages
des usines perché en haut d'une grue il
décharger les bateaux et avec une vue
panoramique sur les cheminées au fil des
manifestations des réunions publiques et
les actions justice il est devenu le
portable les habitants de fosse et la
bête noire des industriels
depuis 15 ans la pollution et son
obsession son combat
aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe
[Musique]
nous sommes nés à Marseille à 50 km de
Fos-sur-Mer enfants lorsqu'on passé près
de la zone industrielle en voiture les
monstre d'acier les autres cheminée
électrique géante nous hypnotiser
puis nous étions saisis par l'odeur et
on finissait par remonter les fenêtres
Fos-sur-Mer c'était un village
embouchure du Rhône où il y avait
quelques pêcheurs et des éleveurs de
taureau
au début des années 70 au milieu des
marais les tailles installe un temple de
l'Industrie
au temps des cathédrales le temps se
mesurer en demi-siècle le temps moderne
se compte en mois en semaines en jours
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
aujourd'hui fausse c'est 17 usines donc
un site Seveso où l'on fabrique des
carburants mais aussi de l'acier pour
nos voitures et nos immeubles des
matières plastiques que l'on retrouve
dans nos écrans de télévision ou même
dans nos vêtements
mes fausses ce sont aussi 16000
habitants et la plupart vivent de cette
industrie
cancer AVC diabète has c'est pathologie
sont devenus le quotidien des habitants
de la ville des études scientifiques ont
montré qu'il était sur exposé au pôle
industriel
alors les phoceens sont-ils malades de
l'Industrie pourquoi l'État reste-t-il
silencieux face et alors ?
Est-il plus dangereux de vivre à Fosses
qu'ailleurs nous avons décidé pour une
fois de nous arrêter pour essayer de
comprendre ce qui se passe autour de la
plus grande zone industrielle de France
bonjour messieurs dames je viens vous
saluer quand même je vous aperçois je
vais boire un café donc je viens vous
saluer c'est la moindre des choses
comment va
ah ben c'est parfait voyez
ça te vire fausse se passe bien
ça te ville pour l'apprécier C4
site de tous les deux vous avez bien
raison
tu
as dit ok tu vois là la cheminée
regarder la pollution qui sort de la
petite cheminée là-bas c'est
l'agglomération ça fait rien c'est
chargé de particules et c'est particules
là c'est de la dioxine et là c'est c'est
très mauvais ça dure pas longtemps c'est
déjà presque fini
c'est que je vous laisse je m'approche
dans là-bas merci
c'est quoi lorsqu'on a vu une émission à
la diffuse la canaliser on va dire sur
une cheminée mais qui a duré quelques
est un bon on voit plus rien mais c'est
ça c'est plusieurs fois par jour répéter
et malheureusement combien ça fait 2
tonnes à la fin du mois ou à la fin de
l'année c'est très important quoi et on
se retrouve devant une industrie qui de
longues de longues de longues Paul de
l'homme malheureusement
il y a pas il y a pas un jour qui se
passe ça avoir des émissions comme ça
PagesJaunes
sur ces images que l'on nous a transmise
nous sommes à l'intérieur de l'usine
ArcelorMittal
jaunâtre que l'on voit sont appelés des
émissions diffuse elles sont dues à des
fuites sur les installations au mauvais
état au lieu de rester dans les fours
Seagal ces chats dans l'atmosphère
chargée en bateau à pied Rennes1
cancérigène très agressif ils peuvent
t'être envoyer vers la mer ou vers les
habitations
l'étude faut se passer à l' rendu public
il y a 2 ans à montrer que les habitants
de la zone de Fos avec deux fois plus de
cancer que la moyenne nationale
Sylviane 55 ans a participé à cette
enquête la plupart des Phocéens refuse
de parler de leur maladie Sylvie elle a
accepté de nous raconter son histoire
on est quand même beaucoup sur faut ça
va être malade ou quoi pour moi le fait
d'en parler c'est un engagement c'est
une thérapie ça m'aide parce que bon
c'est quand même lourd parce que j'ai
en tout premier lieu j'étais obèse
après j'ai développé
une maladie
cardio-vasculaire
on m'a posé un stent
c'était en 2001 en 2002 j'ai eu un
cancer de l'ovaire
en 2003 j'ai développé un diabète de
type 2
en 2008 j'ai eu une un cancer de la
thyroïde
jusqu'en 2015 ou malheureusement
détecter un cancer du sein et je pensais
que ça allait s'arrêter là
mais en 2000 donc cette année en 2018 en
février il a fallu me faire un pontage
en urgence
non je suis dit normalement samedi je
vais passer la visite médicale pour voir
si je peux conduire
Ah bon pour le diabète oui voilà visite
obligatoire comme ça après j'espère que
je pourrais aller chercher la petite
toute seule
elle sera contente ça c'est vrai
alors c'était bien ce matin
qu'est-ce que tu as fait
jour
allez va lui faire un bisou
dans notre quartier dans chaque famille
il y a au moins une personne qui est
malade de la thyroïde
rien que chez nous
moi j'ai eu un cancer de la thyroïde mon
mari a
été opéré de la thyroïde mais c'était
pas un cancer et mon fils est surveillé
lui aussi il a des problèmes de thyroide
rien que nous nous sommes trois et puis
dans les autres maison une ou deux ça
dépend
taux de sucre
la maladie c'est un portable
s'abîme le corps
et la souffrance physique la souffrance
morale
mais et la famille qui est derrière et
qui supporte tout lorsque j'étais mal à
la dernière fois ça fait très peur à
ma famille
même ma petite-fille la peur de toute ta
famille elle l'a ressenti quand même
Sylvie se demande aujourd'hui si l'air
qu'elle respire n'est pas responsable de
ses maladies
[Musique]
un organisme est justement chargé par
l'État depuis plus de 40 ans de
surveiller la qualité de l'air autour de
l'étang de Berre les capteurs de atmosud
enseignement airpaca analyse les
polluants dans toute la zone
nous constatons que d'après le relevé
les normes imposée par l'Europe sont
respectées
ici sur le site de Martigues la pagode
qui a un défaut en haut du secteur et
donc me domine dans l'ensemble des sites
industriels qui se situe de côté de
fausses donc par exemple ArcelorMittal
la plateforme de la Vayrac forme
pétrochimique et puis toute la ville de
Port-de-Bouc qui est juste devant nous
et pour le travail d'être au sud et bien
il s'agit bien sûr de surveiller ce qui
se passe pour les populations en
priorité
avec à la fois les polluants d'intérêt
industrielle on est vraiment des
polluants spécifiques et on s'intéresse
de plus en plus également alors nature
et la nature des produits industriels
c'est beaucoup de métaux lourds par
exemple et puis ce qu'on a fait les
dioxine furane où les les hydrocarbures
aromatiques polycycliques
dentiste y en a vraiment 3 à 3 et
sentiments qui sont extrêmement
intéressant aussi on prend la situation
ici c'est ce qu'a respirer un individu
de Port-de-Bouc pendant une semaine et
c'est à peu près le volume d'air qui est
passé dans ses poumons ça représente une
quantité de particules non négligeable
ici pour fosse de différentes on a
également pendant une semaine ce que les
Phocéens respirer et ce qui est
intéressant c'est sûr qu'on part
finalement au fil qui n'a pas été
exposés on voit quand même que tu vois
la quantité de particules de façon c'est
clair parce que c'est particulier on les
voit pas Halloween USA père mais
effectivement des visualiser les enfants
suite au laboratoire et on va analyser
finalement leur composition peux pas
simplement regarder l'intensité de
degree même si ça va bien sûr tracer
finalement les combustions leur nature
va jouer et surtout dans les zones
industrielles on peut avoir des choses
très variable fonctionne la nature de
l'activité évidemment qu'il y a à côté
malgré la couleur de ses filtres il n'y
a pas plus d'alerte à Fosses il y a
Marseille avec moi tu l'explique même
que la pollution à globalement baisser
autour de l'étang de Berre depuis 20 ans
il ne serai donc pas plus dangereux de
respirer l'air de fausse que celui de
Marseille
mais les habitants de la ville voyant la
maladie toucher de plus en plus de leurs
proches ont du mal à s'en convaincre
pendant des années ils ont essayé
d'obtenir des réponses de l'État en 20
pour comprendre les effets des polluants
sur la santé la mairie de fosses a créé
en 2010 un centre de recherche
indépendant l'Institut éco-citoyen
nous sommes allés voir si scientifique
ils font régulièrement des prélèvements
de lichen à proximité de la zone
industrielle
il faut une vraie carte d'identité des
polluants qu'on trouve dans l'air de la
zone de mesure sur un échantillon une
grande diversité de polluants
les chercheurs étudient notamment les
particules ultrafines qui émanait 6
industriel
la station de radio à Fos-sur-Mer c'est
la seule qui est ici mesure en continu
les particules ultrafines donc CM1 et
inférieur et qui maintenant en plus ça
conseil équipé d'un second appareil
permet d'avoir des informations sur la
chimie c'est particules à chaque fois
qu'il a déplacé ces appareils en trouve
à peu près les mêmes choses c'est-à-dire
environ 80 % des particules présentes
dans l'air qui relève de la taille il
sera fini donc de celle qui fait naître
très loin dans l'organisme
une grande avancée pour les habitants
c'est qu'en fait jusqu'à présent cette
pollution là elle avait jamais été vu il
a fallu que l'Institut utilise cette
méthode là pour comprendre pourquoi le
signal réglementaire permettez de dire
qu'il y avait pas trop de problème de
pollution dans la zone industrielle qui
peut paraître complètement surréaliste
mais la réglementation européenne
n'oublie pas de surveiller c'est
particules ultrafines
donc les relevés officiel de les mesures
pas
autour de l'étang de Berre les usines on
peut a plus de 40000 personnes à Fosses
la moitié des activités travail
l'industrie et une fierté la
municipalité en fait même un argument
touristique
démarrer la visite de la zone
industrialo-portuaire de Fos-sur-Mer
10954 projets d'aménagement de la zone
industrialo-portuaire
par manque d'espace les installations
vont progresser en direction du Rhône
fleuve droit depuis l'Antiquité
la commune de Fos-sur-Mer dispose de 6
km de littoral 3 km de plage de sable
fin elles sont toutes équipées surveillé
est accessible en voiture avec parking
gratuit à proximité
cette année encore la ville a obtenu le
Pavillon Bleu des ports des des plages
cette 23e distinction récompense les
actions menées en faveur de la
protection de l'environnement aquatique
voilà tout ça c'est les courrier
Nicolas Hulot
ça
c'est Ségolène Royal ça c'est le préfet
d'Istres ça c'est la ministre de la
Santé
complètement complètement fou la plupart
de ces lettres sont restées sans réponse
mais Daniel n'abandonne pas pour autant
face à l'inaction de l'État il ne voit
maintenant plus qu'une solution déposer
une plainte pour mise en danger de la
vie d'autrui
pour l'instant il n'a que 12 plaignant
avec lui il doit convaincre d'autres
habitants de le suivre dans cette
nouvelle bataille nous la compagnon à
l'une de ces réunions
ah là là on voit très bien la fumée
noire de les samedis on voit très bien
aussi le panache que fait la Gomera si
je retrouve la photo vraiment que j'ai
l'autre côté alors là on voit le orange
mais c'est à couper au couteau si si
si
sur 360 degré je veux dire sont
conscients de la chose et il dit rien
malheureusement
il travaille dans ce milieu
[Musique]
au tribunal d'Aix-en-Provence au
tribunal pénal l'avocate a déposé
plainte
pour tous les citoyens qui veulent nous
suivre
tu vas direction du vent ça peut venir
ça va vers la mer
en colère tout ça
[Musique]
on
a eu de la chance de s'en sortir mais on
peut pas le dire pour tout le monde
cette industrie est omniprésent dans les
esprits dans le paysage de fosses mais
pas seulement elle laisse aussi sa trace
dans le corps humain
aujourd'hui Daniel seront au théâtre
municipal pour entendre les résultats de
l'étude index mené par l'Institut
éco-citoyen elle révèle que le sens des
fossés est plus polluée que la moyenne
la concentration en polluants dans le
sang et les urines d'habitants d'une
zone exposé en l'occurrence c'était
fausse donc pour ça on a sélectionné 138
volontaires puis il ne devait pas
travailler dans le secteur industriel
parce que la question qui nous était
posé c'était bien de savoir si le fait
de vivre à fond sur exposé au polluants
alors que le fait de travailler dans le
secteur industriel bah ça c'est une
réponse qu'on a déjà oui ça sur exposant
polluants
met en évidence que la population de
fois ça les surexposé un cumul de
polluants on a le plomb ou des dioxine
par le simple fait d'habiter à Fos on
sait maintenant quels sont les polluants
qui rentre dans le corps humain par
quels moyens et rentrer dans le corps
humain non il faut savoir quels sont les
impacts sanitaire et puis surtout on
insiste encore une fois et on a
l'impression que ça fait 1000 fois pour
la création d'un registre du cancer
s pollution présent dans l'air et dans
le sang des habitants de fausse qui les
rend malade
nous nous rendons dans un laboratoire du
CNRS à Marseille où les rats sont soumis
à l'effet cocktail de fausse la
combinaison des nombres polluants
présents dans l'air de la ville
l'objectif de cette expérience et de
fabriquer un laboratoire des atmosphères
qui ressemble à celle du Golfe de poste
et donc dans ce flacon nous avons mis en
solution un certain nombre de composer
pour cette solution va être transformé
en aérosol de particules de taille
ultrafine c'est particules trafic dont
nous voulons tester les faits sur
l'animal où elles vont être émise
pendant plus d'une heure chaque jour
après 6 mois d'exposition 80 % des rats
des blocs des maladies
cardio-vasculaires et du diabète
nous avons choisi de travailler sur les
particules ultrafines parce que en
réalité ce sont celles qui sont les plus
nombreuses dans l'atmosphère on suppose
que ce sont elles les plus nocives la
raison majeure c'est la façon qu'elles
ont de cheminée dans l'organisme puisque
elle rentre dans les branches les
particules ultrafines représenter ici
par les petits points rouges sont tout à
fait capable de franchir les vaisseaux
sanguins elle provoque des réaction
inflammatoire chronique de manière
important puisque ce sont des corps
étranger les polluants contre lequel
l'organisme par le biais on va dire des
globules blancs va se défendre en créant
des inflammations
non ce que nous voulions démontrer pour
la première fois c'est qu'il y a un lien
causal direct entre l'animal qui inale
l'atmosphère de Fos-sur-Mer
et le développement en quelques mois
seulement de maladies métaboliques et
cardiaque
Sylvie
mais cherche aussi à comprendre les
causes de ces maladies nous la
retrouvons aujourd'hui à la conférence
d'un oncologue le docteur Mouysset c'est
la première fois en France
donc la pollution aller partout et donc
il faut apprendre à vivre avec elle est
sur l'étang de Berre le matin à midi cet
après-midi sur le bureau
sur
[Musique]
tout ça
et donc elle aurait été des particules
de fil et elle s'est très vite rendu
compte que les rats devenues obèses
qui développer un diabète donc des
maladies cardio-vasculaires ça finissait
par une superbe lorsqu'elle a fini donc
si on est posé je me suis rendu compte
que
Laura en fait c'était moi parce que
j'avais eu tout ça
est-ce que vous vous avez assisté à
cette conférence mais je comprends
absolument
pour réagir parce que parce que là on
est là on a des données qui démontre que
autour de
DJ n'y a plus de cancer on a des données
qui montrent que tour des aspirateurs il
y a plus de cancer si tu devais
sanitaire
2008 on les a
pas besoin d'être sorcier
intelligent pour déjà dire ok il y a
quelque chose qui se passe et on va pas
attendre parce que le risque de
6000 personnes par jour et après
on on sait d'où ça vient et attention
que les rapports qui sont faits sur les
causes du cancer
minimise totalement ça ne regarde pas
les choses dans la bonne direction
générale il est plus que temps d'une
révolution si on veut
on doit changer tout notre mode de vie
réviser tout de vie si on veut arriver à
quelque chose c'est pas des mesures
[Musique]
commencer à t'intéresser avec
[Applaudissements]
Mathieu
[Musique]
à faire son effet
regarde le prix de la C1
nous nous invitons à une conférence
organisé par l'Union patronale du
pourtour de l'étang de Berre en éco
inquiétudes des habitants les chefs
d'entreprise ont choisi de mettre la
question de l'environnement au cœur de
leur soirée annuelle
les cheminées avec la fumée en fait
c'est pas ça
fait aujourd'hui
ce patrimoine exceptionnel industrielle
que nous avons autour de l'étang de
Berre avec le monde qui l'entoure
on a entendu beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
de choses ces derniers temps vraiment
en fait aujourd'hui
on veut plus entendre ce discours
des industriels qui font du Chantal
emploi c'est pas vrai nous ce qu'on veut
c'est l'emploi et la santé par l'emploi
une la santé les deux doivent être
compatible ils le sont et le seront plus
en plus et donc c'est ça notre en marche
on se fait une petite photo avec
monsieur avec les coordonnées GPS
[Musique]
les industriels juste avoir investi un
milliard d'euros en disant sur
l'ensemble de l'étang de Berre pour
améliorer l'installation et limiter les
rejets polluants
pour en avoir le cœur net nous avons
contacté plusieurs d'usine
ArcelorMittal 3e usine la plus polluante
d'Europe rejette chaque année 24 tonnes
de benzène un cancérigène avéré la
multinationale refuses toutes nos
demandes de tournage et d'interview
seul moyen d'avoir des informations
passer par les syndicats
la CGT nous accueille dans ses locaux
quelques jours avant notre visite un
accident a provoqué un arrêt complet de
l'usine pendant plusieurs heures
[Musique]
personne n'est arrêté les hommes alors
ils sont allés emballer les modules dans
la fumée dans le noir et tu sais le gars
qui est revenu
hello les incidents de ce type pour ne
plus en plus fréquent dans l'usine pour
les représentants syndicaux ils sont le
signe du manque d'investissement dans
les installations
symptomatique du 9 le dernier du 9
septembre qui était c'est une situation
d'urgence il y a une fuite de gaz qui a
été détectée à l'Agglo il y avait 1000
2003 1000 ppm c'est important voir des
endroits de 10 1000 ppm donc c'était pas
une fuite anodine 4h après 4h après on
avait un mail qui tombe et les salariés
peuvent aller dans l'entreprise sur
leurs postes de travail
tout va bien quand il est arrivé en CE
en 2012
tu sais plus où c'est
[Musique]
quand il a soupé ça en CE
pendant les 10 dernières années avant
exceptionnel de
avec deux et on ne sait même pas on ne
sait même pas on dit pas
réellement dans l'atmosphère et le
lendemain on apprend que le pays où il y
a pas été déclenché qu'on a eu des rejet
de gaz dans l'atmosphère de 2 - 4,5
heures on sait pas la quantité de lait
tonne de gaz qu'on a pu rester mais
c'est c'est ça c'est c'est c'est les
prémices pour moi d'un gros incident
industrie à la maman on va on va avoir
on va avoir un accident industriel où il
y aura une catastrophe une catastrophe
environnementale et peut-être même
malheureusement
des pertes humaines
[Musique]
juste si je peux mettre une affiche
et si je peux mettre une affiche
le combat de Daniel contre la pollution
beaucoup d'habitants de fausse le voit
d'un Bonneuil
mais il j'hésite à s'engager à ses côtés
de faire de nuire aux employeurs de la
ville
délibéré de la ville d'autrui
qu'on peut récupérer quoi
[Musique]
Swan niveau
ça fait des années comme ça alors
on a pris l'habitude maintenant
alors là
c'est bon c'est bon
Sylvie a décidé des le premier jour
lettre signataires de la plainte nous
avions rendez-vous avec elle nous
apprenons qu'elle vient d'être à nouveau
hospitalisé
ils ont fait la cour aujourd'hui mais
encore de ressort de sexe
c'est vrai que ça fait longtemps quand
même
c'est fatiguant
ça va pour combien de temps et
après on est en novembre maintenant on a
remis de encore
si vous allez tous avec se poser à plein
ça serait bien qu'il y ait maman
parce que là vous partez à Aix en bus en
plus
du coup que tu es tout seul ce soir tu
vas manger à la maison
la petite
prendre appellera maman
[Musique]
les enfants de Fos-sur-Mer sont
Incollables sur les usines dès le plus
jeune âge la mairie leur apprend quelle
réaction adopter en cas d'accident sur
un site industriel
et technologique
ah oui c'est dangereux mais justement va
et venir après là je présente d'abord
les risques et après on va voir ce qu'on
fait quand il y a un danger mais en fait
aussi des fois des exercices de crise à
l'école voilà comment vous pouvez être
alerté qui vient événement que
normalement je crois qu'il y a une une
alerte comme une sonnerie sonnerie
s'appelle comment sirène une sirène
d'alerte à la population
effectivement la ville de Fos-sur-Mer
dispose de trois sirènes sur son
territoire donc cette sirène elle va
émettre un signal d'alerte est-ce que
vous le connaissez le signal d'alerte
écoutez c'est bien c'est bien c'est bien
fait c'est bien fait mais on va je vais
le faire écouter mais c'était pas mal
vous allez voir ça ressemble fortement
ça ressemble
[Musique]
donc le signal d'alerte c'est un signal
qui va monter vous l'entendez monter
et redescendre
en 40 ans cette sirène a jamais ressenti
à Fos-sur-Mer
pourtant durant notre tournage des
incidents grave en tout lieu à nouveau
sur le site ArcelorMittal le 6 juin le
12 août et le 9 septembre
à chaque fois des gaz cancérigènes été
rejeté en quantité importante
alors que nous terminons notre enquête
est un ancien salarié de ArcelorMittal
nous a contacté pour témoigner il a
souhaité rester anonyme
oui c'est normal c'est pas normal
[Musique]
ça n'a pas été efficace
il y a des filles voilà c'est tout
simplement une porte donc du coup tu es
coq qui fume qui n'est pas étanche et là
elle va se déplacer sur la sur la sur
les communes voisines donc Port-de-Bouc
Port-Saint-Louis
clairement clairement avec les enfants à
l'école joue dans la cour de récréation
des personnes âgées sont occupés de
rien
[Musique]
contactez 20 - 25 il fallait fallait
acceptable
c'est ancien salarié affirme donc avoir
participé à la falsification des
déclarations d'émission diffuse de
l'usine
selon lui il existerait aussi un moyen
de camoufler ses fumée lors des visites
de contrôle des autorités
real techniques
[Musique]
et vous-même vous avez donné cette
consigne
j'ai déjà averti le chef de poste qui
avait effectivement des visites
sont toujours du travail
la Dréal Direction Régionale de
l'Environnement effectué se visite
inopinée dans les usines nous insistons
auprès d'eux pour qu'il nous accorde une
interview
depuis 2013 ils ont constaté 36 en
fraction de la part de ArcelorMittal qui
ont donné lieu à 10h et et préfectoraux
donc 4 mise en demeure
montrer des images
c'est justement les problèmes de la
cokerie
c'est quoi exactement c'est fumer qu'on
voit la sur sur ces images
en fait c'est des fuite au niveau des
équipements qui ont été constatées du
fait je te demandais dégradation
des fours ils ont eu des grosses
dégradation suite à des accidents qui
sont passés en 2016
et qui ont engendré justement des des
des
fissures dans les équipements et du coup
les installations de son plus étanche et
ce qu'on appelle les fuites les
émissions diffuse en fait c'est
des gaz qui comprend les différents
polluants des gaz de la cokerie qui sont
qui sont c'est clair
laboratoire agréé pour faire des
contrôles au niveau des cheminées au
niveau des projets dans l'eau pour
vérifier notamment la conformité de
Serge et par rapport à la réglementation
[Musique]
en fait c'est impossible
moi ça me paraît ça me paraît
assez compliqué parce que c'est quand
même des installations industrielles
conséquente on peut aller très loin dans
dans dans les sanctions
sur le quart d'heure sur le métal c'est
c'est un dépassement de délai donc il
est il est il va faire les travaux il
fait les travaux pour se mettre en
conformité on peut aller jusqu'à saisir
des sommes pour pour
remettre en état les installations où
faire cesser l'activité les différents
déplacements de pollution d'Arcelor sur
ces dernières années n'ont jamais été
suivi d'une amende ou d'une autre
sanction plus importante à ma
connaissance non
est-ce que
l'État est-il trop Clément vis-à-vis des
industrielle Daniel et ses camarades de
lutte en sont convaincus depuis
longtemps
[Musique]
aujourd'hui c'est le grand jour ils
seront tous au tribunal
d'Aix-en-Provence pour déposer leur
plainte il espère que cette action en
justice for a enfin réagir les autorités
alors pollution de l'air la riposte
union patronale des Bouches-du-Rhône
demande à la justice de déclaré
recevable à la plainte de l'association
défense protection littoral du Golfe de
poste celle-ci sera déposé demain pour
mise en danger délibérée de la vie
officiellement que 7 m soit par la
justice et ils se prennent ils ont ils
ont les chocottes
on attendait ce jour avec impatience à
quand même parce que depuis le mois de
février quoi on l'avait annoncé enfin ce
jour-là
650 ans
c'est le nôtre
c'est bien vous êtes déplacé nombreux ça
montre justement en effet les 134
plaignants et les
associations et syndicats qui dépose
plainte
parce que c'est c'est un grand jour
quand même il faut le dire plus que nous
sommes pratiquement les seuls
aujourd'hui à déposer plainte une
plainte comme ça contre X pour
sauvegarder notre santé
concernant de terminer pollution
industrielle oui c'est une première en
France à dire que là on est sur une
pollution essentiellement industriel
donc ce qui en effet et souligner c' est
bien le non-respect partez industrielle
d'une réglementation et également quelle
a été la réponse à notre sont-ils
adaptés enfin en tout cas le sens des
associations inadapté des pouvoirs
publics donc aujourd'hui les habitants
l'as tout simplement que c'est
immobilisme ont voulu en effet de
déposer cette place pour que la justice
travaille également de son côté
[Applaudissements]
mais je crois que c'est une bonne chose
de faite
Daniel devra attendre des années avant
que la justice désigne peut-être un
responsable
juste avant de terminer notre film nous
sollicitons dernière fois ArcelorMittal
le groupe se content d'un email pour
nous répondre il affirme avoir dépensé
plus de 120 million d'euros depuis 6 ans
pour réduire la pollution générée par
l'usine de Fos
mais ils reconnaissent qui sont en
retard sur le calendrier fixé par la
Dréal
quant aux portes de l'usine elle nous
reste toujours fermée
après ce nouveau séjour à l'hôpital
Sylvie se demande plus que jamais si
elle ne devrait pas quitter Fos-sur-Mer
c'est le premier jour que je sors depuis
mon hospitalisation
alors nous quand on était jaloux venez
là avec mes parents ont passé la journée
mon père et mettez les cannes à pêche
et on avait le poisson pour le soir
[Musique]